did you get ups I mean when when you
went over and got into a fight with Leon
you were being interviewed he was
yelling some shit at you while you're
being interviewed and you walked over
and one of the one of things that I like
what you said is he walked over your
hands behind your back
you're like talk say what the fuck you
want to say to me but then when he was
standing in front of you like you wanted
to punch you you're like okay mom you
know first thought was he Sandhya well
initially um I was doing my interview
and he's crossing by and he's with his
corner man and I don't know if this guy
consumes a lot of drugs or what that he
thought that that would intimidate him
he was walking like this looking at me
and like pacing back and forth and I'm
trying to do my interview you know and
he asked me something about something a
date and I say maybe maybe not
and then he tells me to shut up you know
what her everybody watching his back
home from Miami you should have punched
him as soon as he asked you a question
while your interview because that's my
natural Inc scene you know if you're
getting interviewed and some fucking
idiot comes here and cuts your any of
you off well you should get punches
slapped upside your head you know
that'll teach you respect not to do it
and nobody else again I should
immediately done it but I didn't I
answer this question but lightning maybe
maybe not he goes on to say shut up
after that I can't take that my daughter
might be watching this interview I've
been telling her stand up to bullies
your whole life don't go running to
somebody in town so he's picking on me
handle it yourself that's what's wrong
with this country I think with this
whole somebody picks on you go to
somebody else I'm not gonna tell
authorities this hooligans picking on me
I'm gonna handle it myself you know
because I'm gonna see him again he's
gonna think he could pick on me got a
handle in myself you know I'm in my any
of you man you're gonna steal my mom and
I just worked out here just me but out
here you barely want a split decision in
your own country I knock this dude out
and you're trying to steal my shine like
this that that's what I'm saying I mean
and then he got famous off there which I
hate so only thing I could take back
about that night that it wasn't filmed
that him filmed it and be even better
you know he was just gone off in sinus
you know neon got his ass I think it
helped you to know did it help me a bit
helped him more than anything
ya know it helps is people know who
these people knows mas Vidal doesn't
take any shit people known that since
hey nobody for rainbows had color they
already knew that man they didn't they
didn't need to see me whipping this like
I see they like to see it they like to
get remembered ah yeah they like to see
people have consequences for shit
talking in this weird era of constant
shit talking you know I think people
enjoy it they like it and if you guys
ever fight it makes it a bigger fight
for sure my gosh man yeah I guess but
does that like I beat number city I've
been in this sport for a while band
beating up guys would that validate him
to fight me when I meet in the top-10
guy you know still yet to be the top-10
guy you know like but he could get that
fight off that that's a new age in era
that right right that's a concern yeah
that's a concern I'll fight when when
his when he's beaten in the top ten got
I'm gonna be the first guy to expose him
to break his face but until that moment
comes you're talking about the business
head because you already saw in the
personal side any day of the week I will
address you but on the business side get
to my level buddy put in the fucking
work will be the top ten guy knock him
the fuck out did you worried at all
about getting in trouble for punching
someone in another country I was scared
out of my fucking life Joe that's what
I'm thinking
I was scared I thought this guy was
gonna kill me man I might have not
looked it but I was scared out on my
life yeah I get it I'm very cold blooded
you know I get that from from genetics
from my pops in them but I was scared
out of my mind I thought this guy was
gonna take everything I have you had to
do that I had to defend myself
I understand but did you worry at all
about them arresting you or any weird
shit like that over there at me or
nothing I wanted to press charges
ah that's how scared I was but a man
charges because I understand my man yeah
but that's high five so you were in
danger I was fucking hell of in danger
and you do not see it was not just one
assailant him on his crew of hooligans
yeah hooligans lawless people I had to
defend myself I did everything in my
right to defend myself was one against
like three or four dudes and they know
it mmm it's some video that okay I
understand
damn and so the would the police say
that already tell me nothing man
didn't tell you sure I didn't speak to
no police that's amazing no no police
for me up in the Spanglish immediately
we've gone Mew and not big English okay
no big English yeah I mean how many
times you find England before or first
time yeah so like if you go the rest of
your career
you can't go to England oh wow no I I
really liked England did you fans are so
knowledgeable and they were just cool
even the ones that were like till
friends and we said like a funny joke to
me or something cool but it wasn't like
that weird bad energy you know even if
there were till fans
oh my boy till is gonna get you know but
it'd be like funny and how they say
cheeky you know it was a great
experience everywhere I went and the
people were super super duper cool yeah
Brazil's rough if someone's fighting a
Brazilian yeah they don't they don't
I've heard the song there have you super
nationalistic and proud very proud so
they're not into people coming over
there and fight Brazilians they're not
gonna be friendly to you but England's
different men they're very polite